Saludos vamos a seguir revisando un par
más de problemas de movimiento de
proyectiles ya que quiero que entiendan
y comprendan esto lo mejor posible pues
lo que veremos más adelante en física y
en mecánica dependerá de su
entendimiento del movimiento de
proyectiles y espero que esto se vuelva
intuitivo para ustedes después de un
tiempo regresemos a uno de los primeros
problemas en los que estamos en la cima
de un edificio y dejamos caer una moneda
o pelota lo que no recomiendo de nuevo
para nada digamos que yo sé la altura
del edificio que es de unos 10 pisos
Entonces tenemos aquí nuestra pelota y
la dejamos caer y la altura de nuestro
edificio es de unos 10 pisos por lo que
será más o menos unos Ay Dios 30
m de
altura entonces eh Quiero saber cuál va
a ser la velocidad que va a tener esta
pelota justo antes de tocar el
suelo conozco entonces que la diferencia
en distancia es de -3 m porque Recuerden
que estoy dejando caer mi pelota de
arriba hacia abajo entonces la la pelota
caera 30 m y si yo les pregunto qué tan
rápido va la pelota justo antes de dar
con el suelo no vamos a escribir las
fórmulas Pues yo espero que ustedes no
lo necesiten sin embargo tenemos dos
fórmulas muy interesantes aunque también
les voy a explicar Cómo resolver este
problema de una manera más intuitiva
nuestras fórmulas interesantes
son velocidad final al cuadrado es igual
a la velocidad inicial al
cuadrado más dos veces la
aceleración por el cambio en
distancia y tenemos que el cambio en
distancia es igual a la velocidad
inicial por el tiempo más la aceleración
por el tiempo al cuadrado entre dos y
bueno tenemos las otras fórmulas que
también ustedes conocen verán que una de
estas fórmulas las podemos usar
directamente ya que podemos Queremos
saber cuál es la velocidad final cuando
nuestra pelota llegue al suelo
entonces teniendo estos datos de nuestra
velocidad inicial recordamos que la
estamos dejando caer entonces nuestra
velocidad inicial va a ser igual a cer
lo que queremos saber es nuestra
velocidad
y sabemos que la
aceleración es igual a -10 m sobre
segundo al cuadrado Una vez les recuerdo
es menos porque es la gravedad Entonces
nos está jalando hacia el suelo por eso
es el signo negativo y para facilitar
los cálculos usamos 10 m sobre segundo
al cuadrado Aunque la cantidad real es
9.3 y fracción Met sobre segundo
cuadrado entonces podemos usar esta
fórmula ya que tenemos la velocidad
inicial la aceleración y el cambio en
distancia y tenemos que nuestra
velocidad final al cuadrado va a ser
igual a nuestra velocidad inicial al
cuadrado que es 0 por dos veces la
aceleración que es -10 Met sobre segundo
cuadrado por el cambio en distancia que
es - 30
m y tenemos que esto es igual a 600 m
si Queremos saber nuestra velocidad
final usamos nuestra
calculadora para
calcular Cuánto es la raíz cuadrada de
600 y Es
24.49
aproximadamente
24.5 si escuchen ruido al fondo es que
está comenzando a llover y parece que va
a granizar Pero bueno no se preocupen
Aquí vamos vamos a seguir con este
tutorial entonces bueno tenemos nuestra
velocidad final de aproximadamente 24.5
m por
segundo si Queremos saber cuánto tiempo
tardó en llegar al suelo podemos usar
esta otra fórmula la diferencia en
distancias Entonces tenemos
que nuestra diferencia en distancia ya
lo conocemos es de
-30 metros
es igual a nuestra velocidad inicial por
el tiempo pero la velocidad inicial es
cer0 entonces Este término se elimina
más la aceleración que nuestra
aceleración es menos 10 Met sobre
segundo
cuadrado por el tiempo que el tiempo es
lo que queremos
conocer por el tiempo al cuadrado entre
dos perdón borramos esto es el
tiempo al cuadrado de hecho vamos a
escribir bien la t para que no se
confunda por el tiempo al
cuadrado entonces seguimos resolviendo
esto es igual a - 30 es igual a - 5 t cu
despejamos t Perdón t cuadrada nos queda
que es igual a 30 / 5 que es igual a
6 eso al cuadrado entonces Queremos
saber el tiempo vamos a sacar la raíz
cuadrada de
2.44 casi
2.45 Entonces tenemos que nuestro tiempo
es igual a
2.45 segundos
aproximadamente y usamos bueno estas dos
fórmulas y en 3 minutos resolvimos el
problema aunque nos tardamos más por que
estamos explicando cada paso pero esto
se resolvería mucho más rápido en un
examen Por ejemplo si yo les hubiera
dado como dato por ejemplo el tiempo de
2.45 segundos y les hubiera preguntado
la distancia ustedes hubieran podido
encontrar eh con esta misma fórmula esta
información y quiero mostrarles que eh
si usan las fórmulas directamente sin
hacer todas las locas explicaciones que
yo hago Aunque bueno Esto lo hago por
una razón lo hago para que ustedes
comprendan los conceptos si ustedes usan
las fórmulas directamente resolver estos
problemas no les llevará mucho tiempo
ahora veamos Cómo resolver
intuitivamente En caso de que se les
olviden las
fórmulas vamos a limpiar un poco el
espacio entonces veamos Cómo resolver
esto
intuitivamente Comencemos con lo básico
y digamos que lo único que recuerdo es
que la fórmula de la diferencia en
distancia es igual a eh la velocidad
promedio por el tiempo y recordamos
nuestro problema es que tengo una pelota
la dejo
caer 30 m y ahora Quiero saber cuál es
la velocidad a la que llega o la que
alcanza cuando va a llegar al suelo y
cuánto tiempo le toma llegar al suelo
entonces bueno lo único que recuerdo es
esta fórmula la diferencia en distancia
es igual a la velocidad promedio por el
tiempo y que la velocidad o la
diferencia en velocidad es igual a la
aceleración por el tiempo y yo sé que mi
aceleración es la constante de la
gravedad y además Recuerden que esta
fórmula solo sirve si mi aceleración es
constante si no no la puedo usar y bueno
Esto es lo único que necesito Ne tenemos
que mi velocidad
inicial es igual a
cer y bueno mi velocidad final es lo que
quiero
conocer la velocidad promedio recordamos
que es la suma de las dos velocidades
velocidad inicial más velocidad final
entre dos y como la velocidad inicial es
cer la velocidad promedio nos queda como
velocidad final entre dos
y bueno tenemos otra fórmula la
diferencia en distancia tenemos la
diferencia en distancia que es
de -3
m y es igual a la velocidad promedio que
encontramos que es nuestra velocidad
final entre do por el tiempo pero pues
bueno el tiempo es justamente una de las
variables que queremos conocer entonces
Cómo podemos resolver Esto bueno tenemos
que eh despejar o poner el tiempo en
términos de nuestra velocidad final así
que recuerdo que tengo que mi diferencia
en velocidad es igual a la velocidad
final menos la velocidad inicial y
recuerdo que mi velocidad inicial es
cer0 Entonces mi velocidad final
recordamos que esto es igual a la
aceleración por el tiempo va a ser igual
a la aceleración
-1 por el tiempo si yo lo que quiero es
conocer el tiempo lo despejo y me queda
el tiempo es igual a menos velocidad
final entre 10 Así que sustituyo esto en
esta fórmula vamos a usar otro color
para que se note mejor y me queda que -
M es igual a la velocidad final entre
dos por el tiempo y el tiempo tengo que
es menosel idad final entre
10 si esto lo continúo operando me queda
menos velocidad final al cuadrado entre
20 despejo y me va a quedar que mi
velocidad final al cuadrado es igual a
600 que es exactamente lo mismo que me
quedó en el resultado anterior y Bueno
en realidad es con eso lo quiero
demostrar que lo único que ustedes
tienen que aprenderse son estas dos
fórmulas Y a partir de ellas pueden
inferir todas las demás fórmulas así que
bueno no tienen por qué memorizar
demasiado y con estas pueden resolver
estos este tipo de problemas de
movimiento de proyectiles bueno los veo
en el siguiente
video